At 8:07, on the morning of January 13th, 2018,
Hawaii residents were woken up by the following
SEEK IMMEDIATE SHELTER.
THIS IS NOT A DRILL.”
Similar alerts interrupted TV and radio stations,
leading many to hide in closets, pull off
to the side of the road, and even call to
say goodbye to loved ones.
For the next 38 minutes, 1.4 million people
contemplated, for the first time with any
gravity, the hopeless inescapability of nuclear
missiles.
2,300 miles and half an ocean from the nearest
major city, Hawaiians simply have nowhere
to hide.
But the truth is… neither do any of us.
Ronald Reagan made this same solemn discovery
over 40 years ago, when he visited the Cheyenne
Mountain nuclear bunker outside of Colorado
Springs.
Today the bunker at Cheyenne Mountain is part
of the United States Space Force, the youngest
of the country’s six branches of armed forces.
But back then it was run by NORAD, which you
might recognize from its annual tradition
of tracking Santa’s sleigh.
NORAD was and is a real organization — the
North American Aerospace Defense Command — and
it was set up to monitor attacks from the
skies.
If the Soviets had ever sent a missile hurling
toward San Francisco, it was NORAD, stationed
here at Cheyenne Mountain, that would see
it coming and alert the president.
All this amazed Reagan, who, behind a reinforced
steel door, listened to briefings on how the
system worked.
Its giant computer screens and Hollywood-reminiscent
flashing maps gave visitors a distinct feeling
of reassurance.
Here science fiction was reality.
But then Reagan asked the commander a simple
question: What could they actually do, besides
simply retaliate, after the Soviets fired
a missile?
The answer deeply disturbed him… “nothing”.
When NORAD was created, in the 50s, it was
designed to help intercept bombers.
But by the time of Reagan’s visit, the primary
threat had shifted to missiles, leaving NORAD
the task of merely watching, as residents
of Hawaii thought they were, the end of the
world.
Few Americans are aware of how true that fact
remains today, 40 years later, in 2022.
While the enemy has changed more than once
since Reagan’s time, the basic fact has
not: the United States still does not have
an effective defense against incoming missiles.
Read between the lines and not even the Department
of Defense claims to have any protection,
besides the threat of retaliation, against
the likes of Russia or China.
But what no politician or Pentagon official
will dare say out loud is that we aren’t
even defended from a much lesser threat like
North Korea or Iran.
In all technical likelihood, Kim Jong-Un could
flatten any American city of his choice at
any time.
While the Hawaii missile alert was sent by
human error, the truth is that had North Korea
launched a mere fraction of its nuclear stockpile,
it’s all but guaranteed that at least one
would reach its target.
It could happen by accident, by breach of
protocol, through a misunderstanding, by an
irrational actor, or, in theory, a terrorist
plot.
But even fewer Americans are aware of how
many billions we’ve spent trying to change
this… with very little success.
The military is no stranger to wasteful white
elephants or bloated budgets — to say the
least — yet the scale of our missile defense
efforts would surprise even the most hardened
critic of the Military-Industrial Complex.
It’s one of the most expensive defense projects
ever undertaken, though it’s produced far
less than almost anyone is aware of.
And certainly less than most who are will
admit.
Sponsored by Brilliant.
Learn math, science, and computer science
the intuitive way with the link in the description.
If America was attacked from afar, it would
be with a strategic ballistic missile.
Strategic, as opposed to tactical, because
it would be launched from a distance.
And ballistic, rather than cruise, because
it would strike a fixed, predetermined target
— like a city or military base.
Its trajectory would follow three distinct
phases:
First, during the boost phase, a rocket slowly
propels the missile upwards, producing a bright
plume of exhaust.
The midcourse phase begins when the rocket
stops burning, allowing the missile to fly
toward its target.
Finally, as the powerful force of gravity
pulls it back down to earth, it enters the
very short terminal phase.
Now, all else being equal, if you were trying
to shoot down this incoming missile, you’d
want to do it as early as possible.
Not only does it travel slowest during the
boost phase, but the burning rocket makes
it easiest to spot.
Plus if worse comes to worst and your first
attempt fails, you might have enough time
to try again.
Realistically, however, intercepting a ballistic
missile during its boost phase is usually
just plain impossible.
Take, for example, North Korea.
If a Hwasong-15 missile were launched at Boston,
this is roughly the path it would take.
According to the American Physical Society,
it would have to be intercepted within the
first 260 seconds, which would place it about
here.
For our defending missile to get there in
time, it would have to be launched from somewhere
inside this circle.
In other words, we would have to permanently
station missiles above or within either North
Korean, Chinese, or Russian territory.
So too would the actual collision occur above
one of those three countries.
Sure, it could be intercepted earlier, allowing
our missiles to be launched from anywhere
in here, but that would leave mere seconds
for the incoming missile to be detected, for
the president to be informed, and for a decision
to be made about whether and how to respond.
If North Korea were kind enough to attack
further South — say, Hawaii or San Francisco
— American launchers could theoretically
be stationed in South Korea, Japan, or international
waters.
But that would leave them well within range
of a quick preemptive attack.
We do, on the other hand, have examples of
successful midcourse and terminal phase intercepts.
Israel’s “Iron Dome” has demonstrated
roughly 90% real-world effectiveness and Iraqi
SCUD missiles were shot down during the Gulf
War.
We’re pretty good at intercepting short,
medium, and even intermediate-range missiles
— under about 2,500 kilometers or 1,500
miles.
Overseas American military bases and several
of our allies like South Korea and Romania
are relatively well protected from their neighbors,
sometimes even by overlapping defenses.
Though even they aren’t perfect.
The Iron Dome’s 90% track record is only
for the 50% of rockets it chooses to engage.
And the Patriot Missiles used in the Gulf
War were discovered to be far less effective
than was known at the time.
But barring some North Korean takeover of
Vancouver or Cancun, America faces no short,
medium, or intermediate-range threats.
Any missile that would hit the United States
would be inter-continental — which is a
whole different ball game.
These missiles travel up to 100 times further,
7 times faster, and can do a million times
more damage.
Not only that but they go way up into the
upper atmosphere.
Intercepting ICBMs traveling at least 15,000
miles an hour requires hitting a bullet with
a bullet… in space.
To really be effective, they even have to
strike the right part of the bullet.
So…
can we do it?
Today, the system that claims to protect all
50 states from intercontinental ballistic
missiles like those from North Korea is called
“Ground-Based Midcourse Defense” — GMD.
Of its 18 tests conducted between 1999 and
2018, it failed eight, giving it a success
rate of just 55%.
Of those 8 failures, by the way, 6 were for
different reasons, ranging from sensor malfunctions
to launch failures.
Not to mention: the Missile Defense Agency’s
definition of “success” is a bit generous.
For comparison, our mainly sea-based short-range
defense, called Aegis, works about 81% of
the time.
THAAD, the land-based short-range defense
we sell to Israel, the UAE, South Korea, and
Romania, has a 100% track record.
Clearly, intercontinental ballistic missiles
— the only kind America is vulnerable to
— are just much, much harder to stop.
But more telling is how often GMD isn’t
tested.
These are all the tests actually conducted
by the Missile Defense Agency across all their
missile defense programs — GMD, THAAD, and
Aegis — whether they were delayed or happened
on schedule.
And these are all the times tests have been
postponed, “merged”, or altogether canceled.
Between 2010 and 19, nearly two-thirds of
tests fit into this category.
The original plan for the Ground-Based Midcourse
Defense program, specifically, called for
4 annual tests for 5 consecutive years, but
there have only actually been less than one
on average.
Despite repeated failures, testing has, in
fact, slowed down.
This does not, obviously, inspire confidence.
The usual government response is: “Hey,
if one missile only has a 55% chance of hitting
its target, no worries, we’ll just send
3 or 4”, bringing the probability that at
least one does to upwards of 95%.
Voila!
Problem solved.
But this is nowhere near as true as it sounds.
And for a very specific historical reason…
The United States has been trying to intercept
ballistic missiles since the 1960s and George
W. Bush entered office already wanting to
invest more in the program.
But 9/11 changed everything.
Suddenly there was a tremendous sense of urgency.
In 2002, Bush announced the Ground-Based Midcourse
Defense system — which was then just a prototype
with no end to development in sight — would
be declared “operational” in 2004.
It didn’t matter, in his eyes, that the
technology wasn’t ready for prime time,
because the threat of “rogue states” like
North Korea was simply too pressing.
To “accomplish” this massive feat in a
mere two years’ time, Bush did something
entirely unprecedented.
Normally, the way just about anything is produced
— from toaster ovens to $100 million missiles
— is that scientists and engineers first
develop the ‘core’ technology, after which
it’s all packaged together into one inter-connected
product, and finally its produced at scale.
Now, if you really need that toaster asap,
you might consider cutting some corners by,
for instance, starting to manufacture it while
the engineers are still putting on some finishing
touches — what a project manager would call
a “concurrent schedule”.
But after 9/11, Bush took this hasty approach
a step further.
Time was of such great importance that he
started producing the missiles while the technology
was being developed — effectively doing
everything at once.
As one retired senior military official admitted:
“We took a system that was still in development…
and it was declared to be ‘operational’
for political reasons.”
For every other defense project, contractors
have to demonstrate their technology before
the Pentagon will pay for it — “fly before
you buy”.
But GMD was exempted.
What this meant was that when things would
inevitably break, the engineers would have
go back and disassemble the highly-complex
missiles and try to retrofit solutions.
All of this is to say: each missile is hand-made,
and many have been deconstructed and re-designed.
In other words, there’s no way of knowing
each one’s actual odds of success.
4 missiles might be 4 times more effective
than 1, or they may not.
We just don’t know.
What we do know is that independent experts
aren’t very confident…
In 2012, a study by the National Academy of
Sciences labeled the system “deficient”.
Ten years later, the American Physical Society
not only called its current capabilities “low”,
but said they’ll likely continue to be low
for at least “the next 15 years”.
America’s own Government Accountability
Office calls its testing, quote, “insufficient
to demonstrate that an operationally useful
defense capability exists”.
AKA: it doesn’t work.
Today, 21 years after 9/11, the program continues
to run in “emergency mode”, with the Missile
Defense Agency tasked with both developing
the technology and supervising its own performance.
Now, you might argue that despite these shortcomings,
some defense, even just 55%, is much better
than zero.
But there are two problems with such an argument.
First, missile defense is insanely expensive.
Cost estimates for the GMD system alone vary,
depending on who you ask, between 40 and 90
billion dollars — making it more expensive
than the Navy’s latest Ford-class carrier.
That’s an entire thousand-foot-long, nuclear-powered,
completely redesigned aircraft carrier.
This is the quintessential American prestige
project — a 3,000-crew, 100-aircraft floating
military base that makes most countries look
weak by comparison — and yet it was cheaper
than this one (ineffective) missile defense
system.
Add up all of the country’s such programs
and the total cost is closer to 350 billion
current inflation-adjusted dollars.
That’s an insane amount of money even by
American military standards.
But the second reason is far, far worse.
America’s real “Missile Defense Problem”
is not actually that it doesn’t work or
even that it’s stupidly expensive, but something
else entirely.
Something so big it deserves its own video.
Because we’ve only just scratched the surface
of what should be a scandal.
We certainly haven’t done the science or
engineering behind missile defense justice
— which is why, in the meantime, you should
check out Brilliant’s hands-on explanations
on orbits, rockets, gravitational physics,
and so much more.
These interactive lessons teach you real,
useful math, science, and engineering by explaining
the answers to questions like “How much
fuel does a rocket need?”, “Why are some
objects in space spherical and others potato-shaped?”,
and “What is the mathematically optimal
battery size for a drone?”
Brilliant is what I desperately wish school
was like.
They get that you’re naturally going to
learn more when you actually enjoy the process.
It’s really just common sense.
It’s designed around the student, not the
teacher.
You pick whether to start with, for example,
Algebra or Quantum Mechanics, and you choose
when and where to learn — even if it’s
just a few minutes a day on your phone on
the way to work or school.
Click the link on screen now to sign up for
free.
The first 200 people will also get 20% off
their annual premium subscription.
You can even gift a subscription to a friend
or family member.